[Musique]
et
aujourd'hui c'est journée des
déménagements
je cherchais un pote je ramène je suis
encore sur l'acquis lot de samsung dit
hier je sais pas si tu as regardé ma
vidéo d'ailleurs je t'invite à aller la
voir sept pilotes étaient complètement
dingue j'ai pensé toute la nuit le
téléphone en lui même est plutôt sympa
mais c'est vraiment l'environnement
complet avec cette caméra 360 avec cette
vr avec toutes ces nouveautés bixby ce
nouveau samsung dext ordinateur je pense
vraiment qu'il ya des choses qui sont en
train de se passer chez samsung
et ça c'est vraiment génial mais
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de parler de ça
aujourd'hui je vais parler d'un petit
jeu qu'on peut utiliser directement sur
son téléphone super mario rudd j'étais
un des premiers joueurs dessus de mario
j'ai été élevé à grands coups de mario
et là je dois avouer qu'avec super mario
run j'ai trouvé vraiment les premières
sensations que j'avais sur sur mario un
gameplay qui est vraiment sympa et je
vais te raconter ça en détail
[Musique]
regarde
bonjour le renne et toi
[Musique]
le monde
pour la chine ouais ouais c'était dur et
il est plein il est bien plein donc
comme je te disais aujourd'hui on va
parler de super mario au run alors en
fait super mario ron tu vois c'est un
jeu qui se joue à un doigt un nouveau
jeu mario a maîtrisé d'une seule main
donc dans le jeu mario avance toi t'as
juste appuyé sur le bouton pour lui
faire faire ses sauts directement donc
tu as le tour de monde les défis todd et
l'éditeur du royaume dans lequel tu peux
récupérer des objets tu peux construire
des maisons faire évoluer les défis pour
gagner des todd qui doivent revenir dans
ton royaume et plus at-elle tour où tu
effectivement avoir la mission
principale est allés délivrer la
princesse et puis effectivement tu as
plusieurs personnages qui sont jouables
à mario fatalement luigi peach yoshi
todd et odette donc tu vois tu as
vraiment de quoi faire
citant maillot jaune c'est un jeu qui
est vraiment ça parte a plein de choses
à faire payer entre les défis de tonnes
entre le jeu dans les royaumes la quête
principale en réalité et puis je dirais
les 10 à côté le fait de pouvoir faire
évoluer ta ville fade royaume le fait de
récupérer des nouveaux personnages dans
un gameplay qui est super sympa moi ça
fait des années que j'ai plus joué un
mario ça fait super longtemps que j'ai
pas eu un vrai bon mario avec un bon
gameplay et je dois reconnaître que ça
en petit jeu directement sur un iphone
ou un ipad c'est top
même sur un autre un téléphone iphone
ipad parce que c'est vrai qu'il est
sorti depuis le mois de décembre sur le
rail os et les petits depuis fin mars
sur android donc tous les tous les
possesseurs d'android ont plus vraiment
découvrir ce jeu avec un gameplay qui
est super sympa je peux que t'encourager
à découvrir si tu es fan de mario ce jeu
est super cool pas un seul doigt du
pilote
tu vas directement géré et on mario tu
lui fait faire ce que tu veux
et puis c'est vraiment le petit jeu
auquel tu peux jouer n'importe où sur
ton smartphone tu vas dans les
transports publics tu joues à super
mario ron c'est vraiment facile et on se
prend pas la tête c'est un jeu qui coule
il ya une bonne histoire
tu as la plupart du jeu je dirais mata
rien à payer
moi j'en suis qu'au début du jeu donc je
les ai pas je le connais pas encore à
100% mais pour l'instant ce que j'ai vu
de ce jeu c'est que c'est vraiment super
ludique et on s'éclate on va regarder
ensemble on va faire un tour ensemble de
super mario run c'est vraiment je coule
si tu m' tu t'éclates
est ce donc là qu'un petit univers où tu
peux effectivement construire ce que tu
veux tu as une petite boutique up llosa
lui tu peux acheter des trucs avec tes
pièces à la bourre moi j'ai mille pièces
je peux effectivement acheté des
collines tu peux effectivement acheté
des parterres de fleurs jaunes bon tu
connais un peu le principe de sur ce
genre de jeu c'est pas une grande
nouveauté c'est des choses qu'on trouve
dans pas mal pas mal de jeux tu as des
éléments alors il faut mais débloquer
inventons des aventures tu as
canon d'artifice ans il ya pas mal de
choses dans ça je te laisserais jeter un
petit coup d'oeil c'est vraiment super
sympa pour faire évoluer ton royaume en
dehors du royaume tu vas avoir je dirais
la quête principale un élément on va les
voir directement ensemble et se faire
une petite partie
alors le tour du monde moi j'ai déjà
joué dans le monde 1 j'avais déjà fait
deux tours à faire le troisième ensemble
tu vas voir c'est pas très compliqué
mais il faut quand même s'appliquer un
petit peu allez c'est parti
et tout ça avec un seul doigt et voilà
j'ai déjà ça commence bien
je me loupe alors fondu sauter sur la
tête voilà hop un champignon je me sens
et accélère faut récupérer les pièces ou
voilà tu vois avec un seul doigt un seul
doigt ça te fait sauter tapis plusieurs
fois dessus ça te fais des soins peu
plus compliqué tu vois il fait des
figures temps je me suis jeté dedans
mais quel con ça travaille dans la bulle
t'appuie et hop à vii repose hop là on
voit là un autre c'est vraiment super
ludique up paf tu récupères les prix est
une honte us on essaye de pas tomber
sinon tu t'éclates eau fraîche aux aléas
[ __ ] mais quel abruti oh la la
bon ben voila tu vois je suis un peu une
qui chante alors tu as aussi les défis
tôt nous tu vas essayer d'accomplir des
les filles up face à d'autres à d'autres
mecs par exemple son ancien adversaire
chance à rien qu'un pas trop de points
lui 39 à l'été pas trop peur et tu vas
essayer de faire un défi pour gagner
plus et pièces par rapport à lui pour
pouvoir gagner des points pour gagner
des taux d' pour se retrouver dans
produit dans ton dans ton royaume donc
faire mieux que lui en faire des plus
belles figures donc plutôt figure sont
belles et plutôt rap tonnes
[Applaudissements]
hu à pièces info lui et moi à la trappe
loterie derrière tu vois c'est hyper
ludique up par ho ho cette phase des
belles figures bon balade sur un vaste
pièce un peu tout aux hommes du grimp
tapis paf on regarde pas encore très
très bon au moins je débute mais tu vois
c'est si vraiment sympa quoi c'est
vraiment le jeu qui est hyper ludique
qui fait plein de figure quel con kit
mars et le petit jeu tales qui joue
quant à 5 minutes que tu as vraiment
moyen de prêts clac est alors passé pro
[Musique]
on va passer par an aux encore je suis
pas très beau gosse dans cinq secondes
tansman y un peu la nouille
si je veux pas perdre terminé alors
résultats du défi totem quoi est-ce que
je suis devant ou pas est-ce que j'ai
des taux d' attention alors grosse
pression c'est tel culte ou non pour
l'instant c'est pas trop mal j'ai
l'impression quand même que je suis un
peu mis sa raclée au make a wave un
méchoui tour monsieur renard en face à
l'empressement de sears yale
je crois que j'ai gagné voilà tu vois tu
récupères des petites autres qui vont
venir ensuite peuple et au royaume et
savard peuple et le royaume voile un peu
le truc tu vois des déchiqueteuses temps
récupère plan c'est hyper ludique c'est
petit jeu sympa et c'est surtout dans
l'univers mario et là j'ai gagné voilà
maison de yoshi bleus cool tu vois ton
mario finale tu fais faire un petit peu
ce que tu veux on est vraiment dans un
mario tout ce qu'il ya de plus classique
et pourtant avec un seul doigt ce qui
fait que c'est hyper simple téléphone à
la main tu va délivrer la princesse
peach tu vas où tu veux
tu fais ce que tu veux tu t'éclates et
une évolution c'est un mario tout conte
qu'elle promeut un gameplay qui a
extrêmement connue je dirais sur un
smartphone
le fait d'avoir un petit joue simple tu
vas jouer avec un seul doigt seulement
ta l'univers mario dans les personnages
de mario tallec est je dirais un peu
accessoire tu as fait de récupérer une
nombre de pièces donc de vouloir
vraiment s'appliquer à faire des scores
et être au top
tu as vraiment tout cet univers là mario
directement dans ton téléphone qu'ils
soient sous android ou ios
donc voilà je te fais un petit review
pour t'expliquer un petit peu le jeu ça
me juger trouvé hyper sympa je sais pas
si tu as essayé c'est pas le cas
vale télécharger tu verras franchement
tu t'éclates situe là essayer dis moi ce
que t'en penses tu me mets sans
commentaire je te remercie d'avoir
regardé la vidéo je te dis à très
bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos l
étoffe